E aí
[Música]
e por muito tempo se pensou que a
criatividade fosse um poder divino
presenteado aos humanos pelos Deuses mas
hoje em dia sabe-se que exatamente
contrário a criatividade ela é muito
mais comum e pessoas criativas são muito
mais comuns por exemplo eu uma artista
é a criatividade ela não é esse um dom e
sim uma habilidade então portanto ela
pode ser aprendida eles aprendida como
também transmitida por isso é
importantíssimo
exercitá-la
a criatividade ela não é nada
mirabolante
diabólico ou algo fora desse mundo ela
simplesmente a capacidade de solucionar
problemas e não importa a questão por
exemplo nessa apresentação eu tive dois
problemas o primeiro seria o que eu acho
de suma importância para falar não tipo
nessa tipo de apresentação
e eu pensei que e por muito tempo isso
aqui na conclusão no que eu acredito
mais profundamente em mim que eu
acredito que a criatividade tem o
potencial para mudar o mundo
a partir disso eu desenvolvi o tema e
cheguei no tema que é hoje mas segundo
problema foi como eu poderia transformar
a minha sala na linguagem falada em
visual a linguagem visual e eu entendo
muito bem como artista que a linguagem
visual ela é muito importante e quando
combinada com a linguagem falada ela é
melhor ainda portanto todos os desenhos
que vocês irão ver e estão vendo são de
minha autoria e quando você pensa na
criatividade pensa muito nesse lado
artístico dentro atendimento músicos
artistas atores
mas a criatividade ela está presente
também na matemática e na ciência porque
você questionar faz parte
por exemplo e cientistas procuram jeito
de e marinhas para substituir sandálias
e tecidos outro exemplo que eu posso dar
é a vacina de RNA vírus que é uma das
maiores invenções do Século 21 que pegou
uma ideia criativa de uma cientista que
se provou verdade e essa ideia pode nos
ajudar muito no futuro então por isso é
importante exercitar a criatividade
mas eu digo que exercitar a criatividade
é você solucionar problemas e no seu dia
a dia você não vê que exatamente está
solucionando problemas
é porque provavelmente alguém já
solucionou ele para vocês um exemplo
disso é causa se eu tenho uma dúvida eu
posso muito bem pesquisar na internet e
achar solução para mim não preciso
hipotetizar achar uma solução emprestar
ela eu posso só pesquisar e por mais que
na nossa sociedade mostre-se que o poder
do questionamento é o que Avança a
sociedade em algum momento o nosso
crescimento amadurecimento nós
a vontade de se questionar perde isso
porque a maneira de se ensinar maneira
de ensino ela não potencializa
criatividade ela só separa ela da
curiosidade e quando eu falo ensino Eu
não falo somente nas escolas eu falo na
maneira de criar a criança e falando em
crianças e a curiosidade eu vejo a
curiosidade como uma criança porque
crianças podem 500 mil perguntas por
dias e
muitas vezes as pessoas vêm isso como
algo irritante uma fase da vida quando
deveria ser uma constante você
questionar é lindo é
bom então o que perdemos com esse
silenciamento da criatividade nos
perdemos muito porque a nossa sociedade
ela pede por
solucionadores de problemas
e sem eles não teríamos soluções para
problemas atualidade Então se tivéssemos
pessoas criativas capazes de achar uma
solução para os problemas
existentes com o poder da sua imaginação
talvez problemas como o do rio Pinheiros
não existiria mais talvez problemas com
todos os rios já tenham sido resolvidos
por isso é importante a criatividade
essa forma e esse questionamento que se
tem ela sem essa fomentação da
curiosidade e da criatividade e nem
sequer vai tentar achar uma solução para
esse tipo de problema
Ah
e pode parecer que o motivo de eu estar
aqui é que a minha jornada criativa Foi
incrível que eu sou uma em um milhão e
que o sistema não me afetou mais muito
pelo contrário ele me afetou muito em
sim com vários tipos diferentes de
frustrações que eu tive que aprender a
lidar e normalmente não somos ensinados
a lidar com a elas com elas o
os dois exemplos disso são as inúmeras
vezes que eu tive que refazer a minha
fala ou até mesmo refazer os meus
desenhos que não estavam representando
muito bem o que eu queria dizer e muitas
vezes eu recebi críticas da minha
apresentação E eu achava que era aquela
atualização estava incrível linda
maravilhosa mas com as críticas eu me
senti genuinamente triste e eu tive que
aprender a lidar com isso
na escola
eu eu eu me senti meio deslocada meio
sempre isso porque Artes sai do
currículo no primeiro ano do ensino
médio e no terceiro e no segundo se foca
muito nos vestibulares humanas exatas e
biológicas Mas se for que não conteúdo
delas não o potencial criativo de
questionar e questionador delas ou seja
eu fiquei deslocada e nossa na minha
escola tinha um simulado e depois a
simulado saiu uma tabela e você se a
gente ficava com a sua identificar na
sua nota a partir do curso que você
queria fazer no caso eu queria fazer
design jogos muitas vezes eu passei pela
que ela tabela e pessoas comentaram
Nossa que legal alguém quer fazer game
design e muitas vezes eu também passei
lá e alguém falou nossa alguém quer
fazer game design
que desperdício porque eu tirei uma nota
boa então para eles até para minha
família eu estava desperdiçando a minha
mente brilhante e eu acho o contrário
disso porque eu decidi usar a minha
mente para o que me faça feliz que achar
respostas para grandes dilemas da vida
serão ser eis a questão
Oi e eu tive que sobreviver todo esse
processo de alguma forma exercitando a
minha criatividade uma das maneiras que
eu achei que foi a mais eficaz para mim
foi utilizando um caderninho de ideias
esse daqui já é o meu segundo eu tenho
um outro em casa aqui tá cheio e
independente do que eu pense da ideia
que eu tenha eu anoto nele eu não posso
me julgar porque no caso se eu mandar
uma negativa direta para o meu cérebro
eu fecho caminhos e isso é uma
construção que é feita com todos nós
desde criança nosso chama os caminhos
desde sempre por isso que de vez em
quando nos sentimos muito frustrados
quando nenhuma ideia boa vem
E então como é que tá isso como destruir
isso é nos parar de não julgar nós não
julgamos constantemente é como se
tivéssemos um tribunal com duas vezes e
isso não é saudável porque nossas
palavras nossas influências ela nossas
palavras têm tanta influência ainda
nossa criatividade que só não temos
ideias disso mas porquê que isso
acontece isso acontece porque somos
cobrados o tempo todo para ser os
melhores não melhor de nós melhores que
todos em todas as nossas áreas
isso é simplesmente humanamente
impossível de acontecer
bom então precisamos parar no de no
lugar e com essa pandemia nós tivemos
que criar novos meios de comunicação
novos ambientes digitais para nos
conectar e Então por que não deixamos
esse momento é propício para uma
florescimento das nossas Mentes
Brilhantes desse rebuscada criatividade
esse já mudamos uma vez por conta de um
vírus mortal por que não podemos mudar
de novo para o nosso futuro
Então por que não podemos reinicializar
a e agora eu quero que vocês têm sem
comigo muitas vezes
se nós tivéssemos esse rebuscar esse
esse incentivo da criatividade da
curiosidade do ato de questionar desde
cedo com as crianças quantas ideias
inovativas e já não teríamos hoje em dia
mesmo na matemática mesmo nas artes
quantas vezes falaram que o problema sou
sentimentos eram impossíveis de se achar
uma solução e pessoas criativas acharam
colocando um pouco de
números em pinceladas um pouco de si
mesmos para achar uma solução assim como
uma criança então é por isso que é
importante é exercitar a criatividade é
por isso que é necessário é muito
obrigada
[Música]